well Jared Kushner and Ivanka Trump have
now been subpoenaed by the special
counsel and this is a very very big deal
which potentially will lead simply to
hundreds of times over many hours
pleading the fifth depending on how it
goes the New York Times reports Jared
Kushner and Ivanka Trump subpoenaed in
January 6th investigation now you might
be saying David sir hold on I thought
that ended because Congress ended this
is not that investigation that the last
Congressional term ended better said and
now Republicans have taken over this is
not that investigation this is the
special counsel the article says the
special counsel overseeing the inquiry
into Trump's efforts to retain power
after the 2020 election once the former
president's daughter and son-in-law to
testify to a grand jury
the decision by the special counsel Jack
Smith to subpoena Trump and Kushner
underscores How Deeply into Trump's
Inner Circle Smith is reaching and is
the latest sign that no potential
high-level witness is off limits the
article also says the disclosure about
the subpoena comes two weeks after it
was revealed that Smith subpoenaed
former vice president Pence Pence plans
to fight that subpoena invoking his role
as president of the Senate to argue that
it violates the speech or debate clause
of the Constitution as far as these
subpoenas go quote it is unclear whether
Trump will seek to block whether Donald
Trump will seek to block Ivanka Trump
and Jared Kushner from testifying on the
grounds of executive privilege as he has
tried with some other Witnesses both of
them served as White House officials in
the Trump Administration Trump declined
to try to stop them from testifying
before the house committee
um an aid to Ivanka and Jared didn't
respond with a request for for comment
it's ironic how the Trump cult
often overlooks
how Jared Kushner received billions from
Saudi Arabia which is a country they
love to demonize but they're obsessed
about Hunter Biden's laptop and Jared
Kushner who admittedly we don't talk
about that often on this program either
he and Ivanka seem to have kind of
decided for our personal image this
entire thing was very bad and there are
articles about how you know in the
waning days of the Trump Administration
they wanted to just kind of like return
to their old social lives in New York
City and a lot of people didn't want to
welcome them because they were
understandably disgusted so they ended
up I think it was like moving to Miami
but the it's a whole mess but Jared and
Ivanka or at least somewhat connected to
the reality of how they are now seen and
the truth is that they don't get the
scrutiny that they probably deserve as
individuals who were far more involved
with the Trump Administration than were
Eric and Don Jr for example and the
double standard with the hunter Biden
laptop is of course wild and we
reasonable people could point to them
and say you know they made hundreds of
millions of dollars while serving for
the government thanks to nepotism
and somehow that doesn't deserve an
investigation but hunter Biden when we
know 99 of the hunter Biden's story and
his drug issues and the entire thing he
had nothing to do with government he had
nothing to do with Joe Biden's vice
presidency he has nothing to do with Joe
Biden's presidency they want extensive
investigations and hearings and endless
resources and millions of dollars of
taxpayer money going to the hunter Biden
laptop but they're not even thinking
about Jared Jared and Ivanka
um one of the things I do think however
about Ivanka my instinct right now given
the distance that Ivanka and Jared have
kind of put between themselves and
Trump's 2024 campaign
Ivanka has kids that I think she
actually does care about
um I think she would throw her dad under
the bus if it meant saving herself and
her family the most likely outcome at
the end of this entire subpoena is an
eight-hour deposition where Ivanka
pleads the fifth 500 or a thousand times
I still think that's the most likely
outcome but if it really came down to
self-preservation I actually do think
that Ivanka would do what she needed to
do to maintain her immediate family unit
um but that's just a guess let me know
what you think in the comments